hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
midway through the work of st. Anselm
SPRO SLO Jeon we find the argument
taking a interesting indeed even
paradoxical turn because Ansem had set
out to find a single argument that would
not only prove that God existed but that
God was the sole good all other goods
requiring that good and all the other
things that we believe about God and it
seemed like he was making good on that
in the early parts of the work up until
chapter 14 because in chapter 14 which
is actually titled how and why God is
both seen and not seen by those who seek
Him and some confesses to himself and to
his interlocutor God in this and to us
the readers that although he has found
the God that he's looking for
he doesn't perceive God there's a sort
of lack or a privation in his way of
grasping God he has understood God via
argumentation reasoning using the
highest part of our self the rational
mind about God and he believes that that
what he is reason about does exist
has the qualities but he's not having a
you might say completely comprehensive
grasp of the divine substance so he
expresses this by saying that he has
seen the light and the truth but he has
not seen God as God what has he seen
he's seen that God is the highest of all
beings then which nothing better can be
thought he has life itself
light wisdom goodness eternal happiness
happy eternity exists always in
everywhere that's a lot of stuff but he
says if you have not found your God how
is he the one who you have found but if
you have found him why do you not
perceive him why are you not grasping
the totality that is God so he puzzles
here and he says has it not found him
whom it it found to be light and truth
and these are two ways of naming you
could say or conceptualizing God looks
light which Anselm was already using for
God in the modal Audion and truth
Veritas right which is going to show up
in a later dialogue specifically on
truth where God is the sort of capital-t
truth from which all other truths depend
and in which all other truths are so he
says how could you have understood
anything at all about you that is God
except by your light and truth therefore
if it has seen the light and the truth
it has seen you but notice that light
and truth here are sort of stand-ins for
God as good as they are as wonderful as
they are as supreme and superlative as
they are and as much of an important
role as they play in you could say
visual perception and analogously in the
perception through the eye of the mind
or the soul they're not everything that
God is they're not giving us God as God
so again using this visual metaphor and
some talks about his soul as trying to
conceptualize what lies beyond what it
has seen what lies beyond what it is
conceptualized what it is grasped and he
says that this is darkness now does that
mean that insofar as we cannot grasp God
whatever it is that we grasp is
non-existent or false or untrue or
however you want to put it existing in
darkness a kind of privation or are we
looking at this the wrong way why is
there darkness well there could be two
reasons why something is dark it could
be that if we want to use again this
visual metaphor it could be that we're
looking at something and we don't see
what's there why because our eyes are
too weak because in this case an Tom's
mind is darkened as he began this by
this entire work by saying that his mind
had been darkened by the vices and many
sins
so it's darkened in itself but even if
an Anselm is actually quite a good guy
even if we're talking about somebody who
is a saint
who is perfectly good if we can imagine
such a thing and even the Saints aren't
aren't said to be perfectly good quite
frankly if you if you check out lives of
the saints
they could still be dazzled their eyes
of the mind could still be overwhelmed
by the super the superlative or supreme
illumination coming from the divine
light so it could be weakness on the
side of the perceiver and it could be
that what is being perceived is just too
much for that perception Anselm takes
both of these to be the case so he says
you know
is my eye darkened by its own infirmity
or is it dazzled by its splendor surely
it's both darkened in itself and dazzled
by you it is obscured by its own
littleness and overwhelmed by your
vastness so it's not simply visual it's
also you could say quantitative in a
certain sense or perhaps we could talk
about degrees of being it is pinched by
its own narrowness and vanished
vanquished by your fullness so he says
how great is that light for from it
flashes every truth that enlightens the
rational mind and this is as much as we
get of the sort of illumination theory
that Augustinians in the Middle Ages
made so much of an sum does think that
God is the light that illuminates every
single rational mind not only our own
mind but every other one and when we try
to conceive of what that would be like
we come to a kind of you know a pariah
or halt we're not able to fully
conceptualize that and he'll go on in
chapter 15 and reframe this in terms of
the argument if you recall the unum
argument and the single argument took
off to prove that God exists and God is
all these other things as well the
divine attributes by saying that God was
coal mayest kogatana renown posted that
is God is that van which a greater
cannot be conceived or thought however
you want to translate Kogut re here and
some says God not only is that God not
only is that than which greater cannot
be thought God is also something greater
than what can be thought so that that
sounds a little strange let's run
through that one more time
God not only is what Hanselman said he
was earlier that then which nothing
greater can be thought so anything you
can think of
God is greater than that but God is also
in a certain sense beyond even that God
is greater than what can be thought
right so God surpasses our capacities to
think now notice something very
interesting here though and some is
reaching this through thoughts so there
is something about human thinking that
again paradoxically allows us to surpass
human thinking and even to think about
what exceeds human thought so quit Amaya
Squam kogatana repost it is another way
of understanding what God is and some
even provides a bit of argumentation
here he says that since it's possible to
think that such a being namely a being
greater than can be thought exists then
if you are not that being it's possible
to think of something greater than you
but that is impossible so the very same
logic by which Anselm argued for the
existence of God for the you know
greatness of God in so many other ways
justice you know eternity truth all
these other divine attributes he now is
using to argue that God is something
that is greater any than anything we can
even think of he is beyond our thinking
in chapter 16 now he brings this to a
close so he began with a kind of visual
metaphor talking about our human
capacities came back into the argument
and now he's going to bring in a trope
which has been used long before him by
other religious thinkers talking about
God as dwelling in an inaccessible light
what would that mean for God to dwell in
an inaccessible light well God himself
or itself is that light so that would be
part of it God dwells within the
divinity whatever that happens to be and
we're able to penetrate it
- it to a certain degree we can do so
through all sorts of modes including
using the rational human mind and
argumentation so he says surely there is
no other being that can penetrate this
light so that it might see you there
the reason I do not see it is it is too
much from me and again Ansem brings up
these ways in which the human mind falls
short he talks about himself as being
dazzled by the splendour of this light
of the God that he's trying to conceive
of being overwhelmed by vastness being
perplexed by extent and then this is one
that I thought I wanted to take a little
bit out of order from how Ansem himself
arranges these rhetorically vanquished
by fullness there is a surplus you could
say beyond surpluses that makes it
impossible for the human being to fully
or even you might say I mean what what
percentage should we establish whatever
percentage we we pick it's going to be
something lower than that we're not able
to take in the surplus that is the
divine so whatever conceptualization
that we're able to formulate of it and
Anselm is formulating quite a coherent
and rich conception in the prosto Gian
that by itself is still inadequate to
what God is and that is why we can use
this metaphor of dwelling in
inaccessible light we could frame the
same thing in different ways and that is
what he does in these three chapters of
the Mona load the prosto Gian
you